the media in political world are
apoplectic over allegations of sexual
misconduct against Roy Moore three women
allege that he had relationships with
them when they were teenagers and Moore
was in his early 30s one woman who was
14 at the time says he initiated a
sexual encounter GOP establishment
figures and the left are calling on
Moore to withdraw from the race but
Moore has flatly denied the allegations
and he's vowing to fight on
establishment media figures are
salivating over the scandal this is Todd
akin times five this is much worse if I
am running Democratic candidates I'm
plastering the party this is the party
of pedophiles this is the party of of
physical abusers so you make him one of
the poster boys
okay second the GOP is a party of
abusers I don't think they want to go
there I've got two words for you Bill
Clinton now it was reported this week
that another sexual degenerate Harvey
Weinstein employed a guy a private eye
named Jack Palladino and he was hired to
collect dirt on his accusers and by the
way you know who Palladino used to work
for doing that same job Bill Clinton and
you got it and then there's David Boies
the Democratic super lawyer who
represented Al Gore and gave millions to
the Clintons and to the Obamas and was
also employed by Weinstein he too helps
suppress stories of Harvey's misdeeds
using the New York what the New Yorker
called a network of spies and I haven't
even gotten into the rape allegations
against Bill Clinton of course in the
sex scandals involving Weiner Spitzer
Barney Frank need I go on
and the GOP is the party of sexual abuse
get out of here last time I checked
Weinstein Spacey and louis c.k weren't
exactly hanging out at CPAC you see the
left shield and protect their own to the
very end oh and by the way Democrat
Senator Bob Menendez is currently
in the middle of a federal trial for
bribery and right now no one and I mean
no one on the left is calling for him to
resign by the way when Chuck Schumer was
asked about this recently he just kind
of refused to answer kind of moved on to
the next question and who can forget
that after impeachment an impeachment
vote of Bill Clinton the Democrats raced
up to Capitol Hill right after the vote
and they held what was the equivalent of
a White House pep rally for Bill Clinton
the only thing I didn't have his
balloons for that thing and meanwhile
Republicans they throw their candidates
overboard the moment an allegation is
made even if it's 38 years old regarding
Roy Moore as I stated last night he was
not the candidate I supported in this
race I supported mo Brooks so my
commentary doesn't come from a place of
advocacy but rather I want to lay out
the facts as we have them this is Moore
himself answering the charges from our
own Sean Hannity today on the radio
these allegations are completely false
false and misleading I don't know miss
Kaufman from anybody I know I've never
talked to her and never had any contact
with her you understand this is 40 years
ago
after my return from the military I
dated a lot of young ladies I don't
remember ever dating any girl without
the permission of her mother
do you remember dating girls that young
at that time not generally no if I did
you know I'm not going to dispute
anything but I don't remember anything
like that let me go back to Kaufman for
a minute here because this is the issue
here she gives specific instances it
never happened and I don't even like
hearing it because it never happened and
they're doing this a month away for
weeks away after 40 years in public
service I've run five successful
campaign or five campaigns statewide
campaigns three in the county this has
never been brought up if you abuse a
fourteen-year-old you shouldn't be a
Senate candidate I agree with that but I
did not do that and you can say
unequivocally you never dated at any
that was in their late teens like that
when you were 32 out of my customary
behavior that's right
in other words you don't recall ever
dating any girl that young when you were
that old I know and you think that's
inappropriate too that's what you're
saying yes now he did deny it but some
of the answers were a little awkward
particularly that one about asking
mother's permission to date their
daughters and honestly look we don't
know what went on almost 40 years ago
and there's no way to prove or disprove
what these women allege these are seedy
and really horrible charges and they're
very very troubling but this is now a
political question it's not a legal
question should remor remain in the race
and would Alabama Bama voters still
support him I asked my Alabama listeners
on radio that very question today and
here's what they said I'm definitely
still voting for Roy Moore and it's a
hit piece Roy Moore will win an even
larger margin now being attacked by The
Washington Post is the equivalent of
being endorsed by Donald Trump we would
rather vote for a man that has
allegations against him that certainly
come from a dubious source we're not
stupid we see what's going on we see
this they did the same thing to Donald
Trump 30 days or the election we had a
board full of calls the entire show on
this topic because we have a lot of
listeners in Alabama and I was really
struck that not one caller said they
would drop more that they wouldn't show
up and vote for him not one the timing
of these allegations just weeks before
the election is it is a little
suspicious to say the least and the fact
that the Washington Post whose editorial
board opposes Moore's candidacy and then
some is the source and the source of the
bombshell should give us some pause and
that's the angle